eric zemmour des plateaux télé à une
possible candidature présidentielle
1995 première apparition à la télé
c'était sur france 2 lors d'un débat
politique à quelques mois des
présidentielles
à l'époque eric zemmour et éditorialiste
à info matin il en profitait pour
dézinguer lionel jospin candidat à la
primaire du ps lionel jospin est un
piètre candidat jeudi à toulouse il a
toujours été mais elle
attend d'être candidat à une législative
par
un an plus tard en 1996 eric zemmour
devient journaliste politique au figaro
il apparaît de plus en plus à la télé
bonjour à tous ces règlements bonjour
eric zemmour vient d'arriver eric
zemmour vous êtes journaliste grand
reporter au service politique du figaro
à partir du milieu des années 2000 sa
carrière prend un autre tournant eric
zemmour se fait maintenant connaître
pour ses nombreuses polémiques 2006
sortie de son livre le premier sexe dans
cet essai il dénonce une féminisation
des hommes dans la société sont amenés à
prendre les réflexes des femmes voyez
les concepts des femmes les valeurs des
femmes et que c'est une évolution
ni luc table et qui est massive
l'ouvragé fait réagir sur le plateau de
tout le monde en parle c'est le clash
entre l'écrivain et clémentine autain
alors conseillère de paris j'essaye
d'expliquer j'essaye d'expliquer la la
la sexualité masculine qui est
complètement nier aujourd'hui j'essaye
d'expliquer
jeu s'il n'avait pas du tout je sais ce
qui est considérablement d'imaginer et
vous manquez de culture donc c'est
normal donc
[Musique]
2010 nouveau scandale sur canal+ eric
zemmour tient des propos très
controversés sur les contrôles au faciès
dès l'instant qu'on est contrôlé 17 fois
dans la journée ça modifie le caractère
si ça t'arrive et
la plupart des trafiquants
le polémiste continue de multiplier les
provocations il apparaît toujours plus
sur les plateaux télé 2014 il sort son
livre le suicide français qui dénonce un
affaiblissement de l'état nation
continue à résister merci monsieur four
ouvrage très discutée est un phénomène
d'édition on parle aujourd'hui de
zemmour isation d esprit qu'est ce
qu'elle veut a fait
souffler que je vous dise ça fait
bizarre mais bon si ça veut dire que mes
idées les idées que je défends
ont conquis une partie importante de la
population j'en suis ravi aujourd'hui le
journaliste devenu essayiste et
polémiste pourrait se lancer dans une
carrière politique en ligne de mire
l'élection présidentielle au premier
tour ils recueilleraient 10% des
suffrages exprimés selon un récent
sondage
[Musique]